what's what's fueling this comeback well
a lot of it is companies that went after
these huge target slasher that didn't
work out so you had Pfizer going after
astrazeneca that didn't happen at V
going after Shire that didn't happen
valiant going after allergen and now all
three of those companies have done deals
so far this quarter but they are like
you said smaller I'm but on the other
hand that means they've got a lot of
fuel left in this right they all have
dry powder left over they didn't use
last year why are they thinking smaller
just easier to get the deals done well I
think and they're still looking for
growth so these are good targets and
they're so pretty big I mean hospira was
17 billion for Pfizer pharmacy glicks
was 21 billion for a V so they're
nothing to sneeze out there just not
that hundred billion dollar deal that
AstraZeneca would have been what are
what are people buying I mean does it
does it matter do they just want to buy
something is this a case of executives
that have too much money and no I think
it's a case of some of these older
legacy pharma companies just have these
drugs that aren't growing quite as much
as they used to and they're about to
lose their patent protection so they
need to refill the pipeline and so the
company is that they're buying have
faster growing products but will do that
for how do investors feel about this I
mean a lot of times when you see a big
purchase the buyers stock goes down
obviously the takeover rises to the
premium how are investors dealing with
this round to take overs for most of
these the acquirer stock is rising
because they are just so accretive and
part of that is because interest rates
are still very low and it's easy to make
these deals work but um you know for the
most part they like them so is it gonna
continue I mean can we expect to banner
another banner year in MA M&A this year
it should I mean it's showing no signs
of slowing down now and like I said a
lot of these companies still have a lot
of cash because they are doing these
smaller targets and some of the big
targets from last year are still out
there like Shire could be very
interesting to somebody and in a
different tax zone right i mean are we
still seeing these deals where american
companies just want to get out of paying
this insanely high corporate tax rate
not as much because with the changes in
the regulation it's much harder to do
that um but what you are seeing as
companies that do have those lower tax
jurisdictions being very aggressive
acquirers because they can make these
deals much more creative than somebody
who isn't
American one of the things I wonder
about is the strong dollar right i mean
it it has to give us companies more
ammunition it absolutely does and Europe
you know is ripe with bargains and so if
you are looking for something and trying
to find it on the cheaper side that
might be a place to look especially as
you know valuations are rising for some
of these us deals that were saying any
tips for us what's coming up in the M&A
pipeline um i ah women i mentioned shire
the other one people are looking for is
Tessa uh you know they did a smaller
wheel yes and but people are really
looking for it to maybe do something big
you know maybe my lawn or even endo
which would be a huge deal for the
company